[Music]
great to have you here look at the way
your smile just lights up a room you
know it's amazing I didn't realize you
lived in Chicago here for seven years
yeah seven years seven long now you you
have you have I've known you for a long
time you have an accent a southern
accent wonderful southern accent thank
you for noticing thank you
fantastic accent when you weren't when
you lived here you were trying to make
it as an actor did people try and get
you to lose the accent when you're
living in Chicago they did because an
actor with a southern accent can be a
tough sell so casting directors and
people during auditions would tell me
you need to lose the accent and so I
tried my best but I am I'm not very good
at it you master I've been clearly not
yeah you've oh come on I just have to
hunch your night vent through a lot
together we're good to us okay two
months yeah no I mean have you ever did
you ever try and learn any like a New
York accent
I'm trying what can I hear your New York
accent sure oh yeah I tell you Yankees
oh my god
that's absolutely tread [ __ ] sound like
someone having trouble using the
restroom yeah did you
Irish accent did you ever try an Irish
accent you know I just use the Trinity
dancers I talked to that nice oh and I
was a bard
well yeah why do we wear tiny invisible
hats I have to tell you something uh III
know that you met Tina Fey your 30 rock
boss at Second City here in Chicago
doing that so obviously an amazing union
was formed love connection happen there
keep that yourself but you know I was
curious well we have a lot of writers
that work for us that have been
associated with second city and they
told us there's your caricature is still
up on the wall so we went out and
checked it out and it's it's the most
ridiculous caricature I've ever seen we
put that up this is your character at
Second City what
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
what are you doing there I am
celebrating southern culture and I am
75% all right well you came here a
couple of days ago you were nice enough
to say you'd join us here in Chicago and
I understand that you ran into the nude
cyclist is that I did no I did not see
that coming they had a big I don't know
if anyone here did it but they had a
parade of nude nobody yeah nobody will
admit to it a parade of nude cyclists it
was of them it was I was about to say
nuts but it was crazy
[Applause]
you can't climb five somebody gotta win
it in the back of their hand we have a
picture of you of with the nude cyclist
you never lose your spirit do you
outside an urban outfitters hello outfit
yeah